cristiana chamorro primera de la lista
de detenidos hija del ex presidente
violeta chamorros y aspirante a la
presidencia de nicaragua se le acusa de
delitos de falsedad ideológica y lavado
de bienes y activos por su rol frente a
la fundación que lleva el mismo nombre
de su madre juan sebastián chamorro
economista y empresario también aspiraba
a la presidencia por la alianza
ciudadana fue arrestado después que
cumpliera con una citación en la
fiscalía el 9 de junio
félix madariaga la policía lo capturó
tras retirarse del ministerio público es
politólogo ex secretario general del
ministerio de defensa estuvo un año
exiliado después que la justicia lo
acusara de ser autor de delitos de
crimen organizado y financiamiento al
terrorismo
arturo cruz es ex embajador de nicaragua
en washington apenas se bajó de un avión
procedente de eeuu el 5 de junio fue
capturado por los policías y llevado a
prisión por infringir la ley de defensa
de los derechos del pueblo a la
independencia
la soberanía y autodeterminación para la
paz otros tres ex líderes sandinistas se
suman a la lista dora maría téllez
apodada la comandante 2 se involucró en
la guerrilla con tan solo 22 años para
combatir contra somoza fue la única
mujer que formó parte del comando que
asaltó el palacio nacional hugo torres
también ex guerrillero del frente
sandinista de liberación nacional
realizó la operación diciembre
victorioso en 1974 ese 24 de diciembre
ayudó a la liberación de varios presos
políticos entre ellos daniel ortega
víctor hugo tinoco se integró en 1973 al
fmln cuando cae anastasio somoza fue
embajador de nicaragua ante naciones
unidas vice canciller y diputado
otros detenidos son el empresario josé
adán aguerrí el banquero luis rivas y
varias activistas femeninas ana
margarita vijil entre ellas una abogada
y defensora de derechos humanos y tamara
dávila psicóloga con experiencia de
trabajo en el área social